it was the greatest adventure of a
lifetime 106 days on a big-budget
feature every day you're starting in a
different hour the crazy work rules
you're in different environments for a
couple weeks here in New York City in
the middle of the night New York City
the next next week you're in the owl
chamber it was really stunning
we had a special shoot on a Saturday to
make a lot of the photographs that ended
up in the newspapers on walls of Sally
Jupiter's house the original Nite Owl it
was it was a lot of fun so I would
usually I had all the heroes there in
costume we would set up images and then
later on with the art departments
Photoshop expertise recreate all kinds
of events 80s porn that littered the
littered are decorated porno streets was
shot by me because to get right to those
old images was virtually impossible how
do you track down those those actors or
those images we hired some local talent
suppose for me and we actually used the
prison set to make those images and then
at the same time I was shooting some
backstory of Lori and Sally Jupiter so I
would be running back and forth between
the prison set photographing naked women
and a little eight-year-old girls
birthday party it was an interesting day
one of the things that set the tone
early on as we were filming and we were
in Blake's apartment and there's a
broken window and Zach is over there by
the window and kind of unbeknownst
everybody he pratfalls out the window
onto the stunt master there and of
course everyone immediately said thanks
the director just fell out of Blake's
apartment then he turns the whole thing
set up and laughter just ripples through
the status and it was immediately it was
so immediately obvious that this was not
going to be the average film
if everything in Watchmen has meaning
why do dan and Laurie serve coffee in
the AL chef and really what coffee would
they be serving other than fight
enterprises night al dark roast only
available little gana coffee calm